me and my boy peter chilling relaxing my
boy going to get an interview he with me
he gucci nobody going to do nathan
you don't even know where you're at
right
this is the og of the neighborhood
we got the chicken up here
they gave women
what's the youngest a kid has a gun
right now we've got to set the example
so they can follow
introduce myself my name is rhys
brooklyn look what do you want to be
when you grow up
how we keep crime from having that's the
big question
but don't everybody come to brooklyn
especially not east new york y'all know
that
listen y'all know that
this is east new york we're walking
straight down london boulevard right now
me and my boy peter chilling relaxing my
boy going to get an interview he with me
he gucci nobody going to do nathans
so we just relaxing and everything but
he asked me about east new york and he
asked me do everybody come here do
everybody no
if i was from another borough and
whatever why would i come here
this is the medina they get live out
here when it's time to get live so he
walking down linden boulevard that's a
salute man but salute to every other
borough every other brother there's some
thoroughness that would come out here
and would show the ass out here i'm not
saying that but it's very few
a little bit of everything cajun fries
burgers
they do everything
oh gee let them know where we at where
we at y'all ready
all right
he know i'm from out here you can smell
me we went to high school together
yeah
you like that
cash likes that
it's been a red carpet so far with bkk
what's his project up here
do you know what it is i'm not sure
right this is a big one though
there he is
hip hop new york i was in i was in a
couple of little situations and but
i'm from originally from fort greene but
this is where i hang out and you know i
got to have this where i had my son at
okay i'm saying out here
this is called body bag bullet
ball
is this where you live right here well
yeah i got this well my friends outside
this is your left my wife
the wife and the manager
this is my bro he just had a kid ah okay
kitty
this is what we do know this is like
we'll be doing our neighborhood we come
out we drink we have fun we get back to
the
we got the book out right now it's pop
my pops book is out right now comes in
i'm saying my pop's book out right now
it's all it's selling right now so if
you want to go check it out all right
i'll leave that link below yeah
we're gonna do all that but i'm gonna
[Music]
you know that's what i see that's what
support that's what we want out here we
want support but we treat kind of people
that we all work hard for some and
we don't know why we do it but we got to
be here for these babies so this is what
we do
about survival i'm talking about people
dying for nothing
[Music]
we try to support our neighborhood and
this is what we do if i'm saying i don't
give a we get back to the stores
how you doing
nice to meet you and this is called body
bag bullet ball this castle
we've been talking all day about getting
into yeah we went through went through
plaza cypress all that i didn't really
feel missions but now we're going to
show you and then i'm going to we got to
get boulevard we got to get lyndon
because nobody really got it again
everything is this way
it's like a couple of rappers that came
from here
cyprus
that's all i like and you'll see how far
this goes this i got my little
cousin brother park like oh dirty
bastard kids they doing like we
just trying to keep you going you know
what i'm saying we out here
down the block in the building you know
everyone how many floors is this place
14 13. you know everyone
look it's my mom right yeah
yeah all right so you got a nice place
this is cool
so this is what they all look like you
come in you get they all look the same
[Music]
like certain apartments
everybody
so then you got a bedroom
one room okay
so you've always lived here
[Music]
all right guys well i promised in this
video going inside the projects we're
inside it's my house so you know
and it's love like like it's a bunch of
people
we get love so it all depends on your
personality as a person people love who
they
like you could do negative
but if you ain't got no positive over
the negative so you know who's next door
who's over there who's over there i want
to take the tour
hey look it's going to be the real
you will see how much love we just get
yeah please show us
you guys are never lonely out here
no i don't know how people be talking
bad about where they come from oh they
just want to promote negative i could
show you please where we ain't got to
promote and it's love it's really lovely
brooklyn it's just it's who you go
around yeah it's who you put yourself
around but we respect the code if you're
out here doing too much you won't get
dealt with that's just the streets
if you ain't doing too much and you're
just living a humble life you're going
to go you're going to live a long time
it was more about respect the business
would be sex
these millennial babies that's that's
the problem with that millennial
just like when we was in cyprus and that
happened yeah i'm an age baby
baby right right
anything after pretty much 95 we don't i
don't know about
so you put your elders on a pedestal
pretty much
that's why we got it
a conversation
you then it's about supporting your
people
we get more support i told you this man
right here saved my life one day i got
my jaw broke right here in the middle of
the street
he saved my life
what about this tap over here it's the
wu tank type it's my family you know i
got to stamp when i was a kid what i'm
saying and i just represent my family
because i was born into this routine
no all you guys get in here but we're
just gonna this is like a picture this
is a picture this is for the thumbnail
of the video i got you you see
[Music]
just don't drop any bloods or crips
now we ain't doing that
yeah you don't even know where you're at
right this is the heart that's what a
lot of rappers like kj pulling them from
we might go to our troubled childhood
triple a but everybody had a family we
try to look out for each other that's
what i'm saying because we all we got is
us you know i'm saying this oh we got it
no nobody's lonely out here nobody's
nobody we helped out please we hang out
in front of the buildings all the time
how you doing
she talked to me every day look how you
doing
and she always say hi to me every day i
i'm internationally known she's asian
and she ate trying to build businesses
for our families like we trying to do
for our people any type of people
that think like us what i'm saying
because
each one teach one and sometimes we all
went through trials and tribulations and
we go through look at my brother
right here that's my older brother
that's eat money what i'm saying imani
that's that's kim manager he used to be
around rodkim that's my older brother
like i won't even lie to you like this
real we could teach up like i'm
really wu tang's feeling this
real someone said so i just want
people to know about brook like we don't
watch a lot of people die out here and
i'm not from here i'll just watch people
i got dead on my body to show you
that i grew up with real estate and i'm
tired of people dying i'm talking about
people dying how do you change things
how do you change it
what are they doing right now
being outside being outside with your
people showing people that kids don't
run this world we adults run this world
so right now the kids are they're
running yeah
nobody's being parents no more nobody's
stepping up grabbing their nuts
ain't no fathers in the creek thank you
ain't no father are you are you guys
fathers yeah
and look i don't even get to see myself
but my son know who i am and he's not
going to make no mistake because he know
who his father is because i i walk the
streets i do positive stuff so
so you're saying with the youth there's
no uh there's no god
there's no discipline they don't even
listen to their own parents
thank you that's what it is
bro let's keep it real let's keep it
real they gave us they gave they gave
women a lot of a lot of power too that's
true why why why welfare and everything
gave uh gave women the money
why not the father so we can control
what's
that's right
working on garbage trucks he out here
working for our neighborhood real nick
[Music]
around here
are you what are you what are you
barbecuing
can i take a look can we take a look
let me show you yeah
new york
homeless person that's hungry right so
you're feeding them people on the
streets many times
but they just walk by they smell it and
they smell it yeah they want some of
this i want some of that he got the corn
all right
how'd it taste
east new york
okay let's go
you got some paper towels
you got some paper towels can i turn it
over how you like it that's really good
listen how you liking that chicken man
it's a two brothers jerk chicken man
he's feeling that i'm feeling it
inside nice job stanley avenue
you get some of that you avenue come get
some of that everything will be going
down how you feeling
uncle b all right
of course good luck very good food he
always got a barbecue in his pocket
that's uncle b.o dj east new york
all right
you speak arabic
um some a little bit yeah
oh you have some of that chicken that's
good did you get some chicken yeah yeah
take care of guys
all right you wanted to show me a store
right
i don't live here i can't vote but thank
you thank you there you go
you're not in there
this is my young boy that's what i
always
he's a businessman this is a real
business man you know why i like him
because he he's smart he's not dumb and
he don't take no you hear me and he
supports his people like for me and this
is almost respect this is love we all
the different nationalities but we know
i learned how to stick together and
that's what it's about i'm saying that's
how you take care of generations i used
to sell turtles on eastern parkway baby
turtle baby real
turtles real turtles baby turtles on
eastern parkway that was my hustle i
used to go to the chinese people get
turtles for 10 cents
and come to the streets and sell them
for 10 hours if you went to eastern park
right now when you get off the four
train three that was me right there baby
turtle turk baby
so we teach our kids how to hustle water
we teach our kids how to hustle anything
is a hustle as long as you can make some
legit money
that's a business
the answer when you ain't got no
opportunities thank you ain't nothing
wrong with selling drugs unless you're
doing what you got to do with it if you
got a seller take care of families take
care of family you got to sell it to
pick yourself in a better position do it
drugs is an option for when you ain't
got nothing going on in the hood you
understand so somebody got your house or
something
tylenol is a drug so wait you're for
selling
drugs pro choice
i'm pro-choice pro drug choice yeah i
ain't for it but if i got to feed my
family one day it's like a have i
gotta feed my favorite and that's the
last result i'm gonna
think about it got you right now think
about all the people that went to jail
for drugs now marijuana all that like
years in life and now they're making it
legal
yeah
that's right now all the design the
celebrities got strands of weed but
people like us go to jail before we try
to promote it
all
what about fentanyl because there's
drugs
that's bad that's knocking people off
whoever's dropping that he's doing it
they got to be coming from the hospitals
and stuff because ain't no just
know we're fed in all that yeah okay so
when because no let me explain this guys
because a lot of people think drugs and
they're thinking like marijuana and
fentanyl are two different universes
it's amazing all right it grows it grows
marijuana you can never say and i don't
care i don't know
to this day on this interview thank you
marijuana never killed nobody and i've
been born in nineteen i'm gonna kill
nothing nobody gotta get better now
there's killing we all gotta come
to a reality like what makes sense in
this world how we keep crime from having
the got that's the
and i'm telling you how we doing it now
support your people and make sure that
you police your people we don't need
them to police us we know who bad and
doing
how do you please can
but we ain't gonna kill you
because we have to kill you that means
you gotta die because that means you're
trying to hurt the family yeah
that's the only way what do you got
there when you got some weed
oh you got weed huh
we was young we was manipulated by the
older ones that came before us yeah yeah
so it's always somebody being
manipulated by somebody that came before
them yeah so how do you not manipulate
they stay away from them that's
manipulating this yeah
bottom line if my mother told me i'm
down the block over there selling
drugs down there playing basketball
where you gonna go hang at all right
somebody's getting a lot of money but
now i'm gonna chill with cool kids i
know they'll be shooting down there so
let me make it i'm going down
yeah
i know i ain't gonna get shot down here
but if i go down here i'm like getting
robbed shot okay anything
what's the youngest a kid has a gun
right now what's the youngest side you
can't even find your age on it bro half
of these kids by fight right now six
years you wouldn't even know they
might get carried because they already
know about it's a regular household they
already exploit that might they might
take your gun they might they might damn
how many times you're older than us
you're the auntie of the block
you know everyone in here i know mostly
everyone in here are you keeping people
in line trying cool
she does keep us in the room don't try
nobody messes with auntie
no
this is the og of the neighborhood we're
out of the building or the building
building and the little homies that be
out here okay i'm 53 i spent 16 years in
jail broke my neck while i was in there
and i came over here and linked up with
the little kids around here and became
like we gotta put on first we can't let
a father figure too
so what do you what do you what are you
seeing now with the younger generations
honestly i'm seeing a lot of things that
i'm not liking
but there are a lot of things that i do
see a lot
so every day when i see one of the young
brothers going through some problems i
try my best to talk to him and let him
know at least what i've been through
what do you what do you tell them
i tell them everything i tell them about
my 16 years in jail
tell them i tell them about how i played
i was playing basketball while i was
incarcerated and was paralyzed for three
and a half years
i had to have a surgery perform have
them take a bone out my hip to put in my
neck and all that you know i tell them
these things like if y'all stay on the
path y'all going on
y'all going to be either like me or
worse than me
right you know i like i said i've been
in here so long i've seen things
that a grown man shouldn't see okay you
know being in prison having another man
tell you to bend over squat open your
butt cheeks and things like that another
man shouldn't have to go through that
yeah the things i've been through i
don't wish that on my worst enemy so you
try to guide the youth i try to let them
know once i see they going on a path
that i was going on yeah i try to like
talk to them and let them know like yo
listen man there's only two places
you're going to end up living that life
one is going to be in the penitentiary
for the rest of your life or somebody's
going to be putting you in the grave
yeah so to prevent that from happening i
try to talk to them so what can they do
to not go down that road
go down the road of uh prison or or
being in the grave like what are the
good out outs here what are the good
outlets here what are the good things
basically sports
not even i can't even say sports because
that's a stereotype okay
become you get you a decent job find you
a good woman
and just live your life without all the
negativity the drama and the bs
you know just go about days on a regular
basis
live your life one day at a time
you know talk to people you going
through something
ain't nobody gonna help you if they
don't know what you're going through a
closed mouth don't get
fed so if you come outside and you're
going through something step to somebody
that you deal with be like yo can i talk
to you for a minute and hear that person
out and get his opinion
and get what you can from them
so i come out here every day i sit out
here get my little drink with them on
and all that that's like one of my good
brothers yeah
mr hallway's awesome great wisdom thank
you i appreciate it no thank you do you
want to see some exclusive no i
gotta oh gee i want to keep og going
he's really og is amazing
you know and i sit here and i laugh at
them about
i was like these guys running around
acting crazy just standing there doing
things that i knew i wasn't supposed to
do and it's sad that i went where i had
to go to learn
the things that i know now
and it's sad as a as a man your parents
and your uncles and everybody's supposed
to teach you what life is about i
shouldn't have to go to a penitentiary
system
and learn from people that i don't know
i grew up in brownsville projects
back in the 80s and 90s well i can't say
the 90s because i went to jail in 89
okay but being in the late 70s in the
early 80s
growing up in that neighborhood
all i had
to guide me was what i saw on the
streets
that's when crack first hit out you know
and the crack dealer would come to a
younger individual just give them some
crack and a gun and be like yo hole is
blocked down
so that's what i learned so what were
the choices was there was there like no
i don't want to take the crack and the
gun and hold the block down or you sort
of had to
wait i had to not i'm not gonna say i
had to i chose to yeah because i seen
that's what everybody was about and
that's what everybody
so if you didn't become part of that
you'd be left out
put it like this
after i got incarcerated
about
three months after i got incarcerated i
got my family got a call from mta
for me to be working in mass transit
uh-huh i was in jail couldn't get the
job
so if i would have decided not to do
that
and stay home and got that job there's
no telling what i could have been right
now
i wouldn't have been semi-paralyzed
you know i would have had a problem with
a car a nice house
at this age i think i've been retired
right now living the life of a rally
but unfortunately
i chose that path and a lot of people
feel realized when you walk in a path
it's not only two directions there's
multiple directions you can go in you
can either go to legal illegal or the
stupid way the stupid way is what's
going on now and these guys riding
around shooting people for no apparent
reason
and that's something i can't live by
you know my peoples and people in
general are dying because of nonsense
basically i mean that's what it is man i
mean anything you want to know
no thank you so much thank you no
problem appreciate it thanks for opening
up on camera i got no problem with that
a lot of wisdom in there i'm good i'm
good with the heart you gotta excuse my
shirt man i'm in the house
uncomfortable tell me the
that's a little shirt
nothing like that but i don't mind
recording and putting in no video or
anything like that it's very nice though
this is like a like a park over here
this whole area this treat-in area oh
yeah the bigger guy
put that on youtube
what'd you say what'd you say we need a
bigger park out here we need a bigger
pump in a better park
what they do with them eight billion
dollars
[Music]
what's your name
what's up carter carter
carter what grade are you
fourth
what do you want to be when you grow up
an actor an actor okay you're doing it
because you're on you're on youtube
right now it's a cool playground yeah
could you come out here doing kovid
no no you had to stay inside yeah yeah
the park was locked up yeah was it tough
not playing yeah
this is cooler than fortnight though
right yeah all right good to see your
friends again so the guys were talking
about before there are way more things
to do here like yeah karate programs
they had program like karate basketball
tournaments pewdiepie
people go downstairs and eat breakfast
lunch they don't be drinking all that
down
at school and get free lunch when you
couldn't eat they stopped a lot
man thank you so guys from an outside
perspective i've lived overseas this
doesn't look bad to me not
good and then inside the apartment it
was nice it was fine right but the
resources you're saying like the
programs for kids to get in the past
all they see
in front of them we their resources
we're the closest resources they got as
who we are we got to set the example so
they could follow that's all they say
example because they're younger than we
the old we don't we the new we the new
generation that's holding down so
if we don't set the right example they
gonna they going they're not gonna get
the right example yeah this ain't about
it's just we like i said it's just about
living life we understand each other
because we live out with each other
every day i'm who you in system real
quick new york but i'm not rapping today
nobody gonna rap allow me to introduce
myself my name is reese the young
goddess from the east rap brooklyn to
the fullest but i and petty dope boys on
my cut hating hate my guts say i
got an attitude
i never knew she just came outside
brooklyn
real brooklyn at this challenge
give a chance for a brand new start
can't walk through the park because it's
crazy after dark
keep my hand on the gun because they got
me in the run
feel like an outlaw open last question
you want some more living honesty
don't push me because i'm close to the
edge
all right that's the guardian
it's true guys i'm gonna wrap you up
can you walk super closely to me
all right guys y'all here with my son
peter and this is good love out here
because we all out here to change
something for something so we're going
to get on these cameras we ain't going
to expose ourselves we're going to do
something better for our people and this
how he changed people's minds and work
because people got to watch his page and
watch what he want to post so how we
going to make this work
here's how we're going to make it which
one teach you
all right guys thanks for coming along
on that journey you know that should be
outside there was a lot in there it was
quite exhilarating quite interesting
in a world most of us don't know
one last thing guys i'm going to drop
the piece to my pod recipes
before we drop everybody pop that loose
everybody that loves somebody everybody
everybody everyone
everybody
all the time
we make everything count
anywhere
all right guys
thank you so much for bringing man
wouldn't have gotten into these
neighborhoods no way ever on my own so
without these guys for making it happen
none of us would have seen this so
thanks for coming along
i'm going to drop a bunch of links down
below there's some great music some
really interesting food we've really got
no fist bumps
all right no colors no colors
thank you guys so much for bringing me
in
all right until the next one we bring
you to brownsville
and i believe kashmir is over here
somewhere
maybe in one of those buildings
thinking there he is there's the man
cashmere
thanks for meeting up